hey I'm Joe Weisenthal co-host and
wonderment the chart I'm looking at
today could not be more simple so this
morning we got a retail sales report it
was okay nothing too special right in
line there were some good upward
revisions to prior months so it's good
but here's a number that stood out to me
look at the year-over-year growth in
retail sales at restaurants and bars
whereas the census calls them food
services and drinking places nine
percent growth this is one of the
highest readings we've had since the
crisis this is a higher level than what
we were seeing before the crisis you
can't convince me that the consumer
isn't feeling good and doing pretty good
when you see them going out to eat and
going out to drink at these levels it's
not everything but to me this is a
pretty good sign when you see people
going out like this that things aren't
too bad with the US consumer and their
forward to US economy that's my color
chart watch what you miss at four pm
eastern time
you